okay today I'm going to talk to you
about transformers so all the
Transformers are that they are things
which can change the size of the
potential difference so remember the
term potential difference means exactly
the same as volts of voltage okay so
they're just things that change the size
potential difference so in order to get
our heads around why we actually need
transformers let's just think about
generating electricity so let's say
we've got a coal power station here
where we've got a turbine which is
turning and then we have a turns of
magnet within a coil of wire this here
is our generator we generated
electricity now before that we can get
take this electricity from the power
plant to homes we use something called a
step-up transformer now what this does
is it increases the potential difference
we'll get to why in just a second so we
then need to transport this this
electricity across in wires um using
pylons then we have another transformer
at the other end this time called
a step-down transformer then that
electricity can go into our homes so we
could use it in our homes so why bother
increasing the voltage here or potential
difference here and decreasing the
potential difference here now the answer
to that is because of energy loss when
we're transporting electricity over long
distances we don't want to be losing any
energy so let me show you that using an
equation P equals equals I times V when
power equals current times voltage or
potential difference so let's say a
power is a hundred and to begin with our
current is
and our voltage or potential difference
is also 10 now if we keep the power the
same but we let's say we are able to
increase a voltage or potential
difference to 100 as a result it by
looking at this equation if we increase
our potential difference
our current will decrease so these two
things are inversely proportional as
long as the power stays the same so by
increasing the voltage in a step-up
transformer we are reducing the current
so why do we want to reduce the current
now the reason for that is if we've got
a high current when we're transporting
the electricity over long distances we
have a lot of energy loss to the thermal
store so all the way along this wire
when we're transporting it if we have a
high current
we're losing energy all the way so by
using a step-up transformer we can
reduce the amount of energy loss by by
reducing the current the energy
potential difference in in the National
Grid is actually increased to around
400,000 volts so why do we need a
step-down transformer so the reason we
need step-down transformer is we do not
want 400,000 volts coming through our
plug sockets in our house it would
destroy our appliances it would not be
safe so we need to get it down to 230
volts so it's safe to go into our homes
so how to step up and step down
transformers actually work so all I'm
going to do is going to do a diagram of
each so all that the step-up transformer
is so just right now I'm going to show
you a kind of simplified version of this
here is we have what's called a primary
coil and a secondary coil okay so from
my power station I've produced an
alternating current that means the
current is going to be flowing one way
and then the other way then the other
way than the other way okay
whenever I have a current flowing
through a wire it produces a magnetic
field around that wire
so as the alternating current flows
through this will earth through this
wire here on my primary coil I'm
creating a magnetic field so this
material here is actually iron because
iron is magnetic it means that when we
have this magnetic field being created
by the electricity flowing through this
wire we created a magnetic field which
can be carried through this magnetic
core it can be carried from this primary
coil here to this secondary coil here
now notice on a step-up transformer
there are more turns on the secondary
coil than the primary coil so I can just
by looking at this I can tell this is
step-up transformer because there's more
turns on the secondary than on the
primary okay whenever we have a
constantly changing magnetic field we
actually induce a current in this wire
here a changing magnetic field induces a
current in this one here again it's
going to be an alternating current
because we have a constantly reversing
magnetic field because we have more
turns on this coil here than on this
coil here our voltage is going to
increase so let's have a quick look at
the structure of our step-down
transformer we got similar kind of idea
but in Reverse so here's just an example
of step-down could transformer now the
difference for the step-down transformer
is it's just the opposite again we have
alternating current but this time we
have more turns on the primary coil
compared to the secondary coil so this
time round as the electricity passes
through here we establish a magnetic
field because it's alternating current
that current is going to create a
constantly changing magnetic field
throughout this iron core this changing
magnetic field is going to induce a
current in the wire on our secondary
coil and because we've got more terms on
our primary than our secondary it's
going to step down the potential
difference ie
decrease the potential difference so
that is how transformers work they
change the potential difference a
step-up transformer increases potential
difference in order to minimize the
amount of energy loss as we transport
the electricity over long distances a
step-down transformer
decreases the potential difference so
it's safe for that voltage that
potential difference to be used in our
homes thank you